it's Monday January fifth and you're
watching the first game spot news
episode of 2015 happy new year I'm now
the host of GS news at least for this
week Consumer Electronics Show is
kicking off in Las Vegas later this week
so get ready for some news about
bluetooth utensils and other weird
electronic stuff that you can't afford
let's get started you know how everyone
is just content to pay a big fat cable
bill and stick a big old cable box
underneath their TVs just to watch cable
channels yeah me neither Dish Network a
satellite TV provider in the US
apparently recognizes this and has
announced sling TV a service that will
let you stream a variety of cable
channels to a variety of devices
including the Xbox one but not including
every other game console yet twenty
dollars a month will get you ESPN espn2
TNT TBS Food Network HD TV cartoon
network and disney channel twenty bucks
will also get you a subscription to play
station now Sony's game streaming
service that launches this month in
North America coming first to ps4 and
then to other devices PlayStation now
subscriptions will offer access to an
online library of more than 100 ps3
games including infamous killzone 3 god
of war ascension madagascar 3 planet
mini-golf pure chess interpol the trail
of dr. chaos and war the pricing of
twenty dollars per month or $45 for
three months is for access to the whole
catalog but if you don't fancy
subscribing you'll be able to rent
specific games for less ps4 owners will
get a one week free trial when
PlayStation now launches in north
america on January thirteenth if you're
waiting on picking up that $350 xbox one
bundle until after the holidays surprise
that ship has sailed and you blew it the
Xbox one is back up to 400 bucks putting
it on par with PlayStation 4 in terms of
price that is not like sales because the
Xbox one is still more than a little bit
behind its main competition but the
holiday price cut did give it a
significant boost just how significant
will
come clearer once sales data for the
holiday period is released early this
month and finally here are some pretty
pictures from the witcher 3 wild hunt
collector's edition you're supposed to
show the video whoo these are apparently
going to be images on the steelbook
cover of the game though we're not
exactly sure if it's going to be six
versions or three versions with two
images per side or like some mega
accordion pull out thing or what don't
worry about it too much for now just
lose yourself in the dreamy eyes of
commander skull face here mmm smolder
okay that's it tune in tomorrow for the
latest news from CES or maybe just some
more pretty pictures either way should
be a good show see you then